this question again like the the
slipping ladder
it's a classic question that's why I've
given it a title the shifting shadow and
it's really important and again it's a
bit counterintuitive so that's why we
should really think carefully about it
okay it's kind of like a similar example
so here is a person lit by a streetlight
at night and they are going to in a
second we're going to draw them walking
away from the straight line okay they're
walking in this direction okay and the
question that's going to be asked is all
about as the name suggests the shadow
that's cast by the person from the
streetlight okay so before I actually
explain what the question is let's get a
bit of a better sense of what's
happening okay this streetlight here
let's do an extra construction to
indicate that in our particular example
this streetlight is 6 meters suspended
off the ground vertically okay so this
is a right angle here okay
for the sake of simplicity let's call
this person 2 meters tall which you
might say say you know it sounds
ridiculous but LeBron James is actually
2.03 meters tall so there you go till
one desk to one significant figure we
have a two meter tall person okay now
where will their shadow be if this is
where they are standing in relation to
the straight line which side of it will
the shadow be on and we on the right
hand side right it's this part over here
that the light doesn't quite reach okay
so if you drew a line from the straight
line to the top of the bronze head okay
and kept it going along the end here
right this spot here here is the shadow
right so in fact I'm gonna label that
shadow okay
and then we've got a right-angled
triangle that sort of forms around this
okay now before we actually write it
down I'm just going to say to you what's
going on okay there are two questions
we're going to ask of this number one
how fast is here's the tip of the shadow
right here's the edge how fast is the
tip of the shadow moving as this person
walks I'm gonna tell you their speed in
a second how fast is that moving and
secondly how fast is the shadow growing
we said again how fast there's a shadow
growing because you can imagine if we
rewind the clock right and have LeBron
standing right underneath the lamp then
he doesn't have a shadow really it's
right beneath him okay it's not long
like this okay but the second he starts
moving the shadow begins to form and the
further he is away the longer the shadow
be yeah this is just like it's sunset
your shadow is really long at sunset
because you have a really long triangle
being formed between you and thus the
Sun and where your shadow ends does that
make sense okay let's put one more piece
of information on here which is that
LeBron is walking at a very casual 1
meter per second okay so we've got a
rate we've got a situation okay now this
time I'll write it down for you and I
watch it again think about it I'm going
to give you a bit of thinking time part
a is how fast is the tip of the shadow
there it is I'm gonna label it for you
part a is how fast is the tip of the
shadow moving okay so I guess we could
say what is the tips speed it's going
that way how fast PI B is the shadow
itself is getting longer and longer and
longer okay so at what speed is the
shadow growing
how fast is that tip moving how fast is
the shadow getting longer and longer and
longer I want to remind you of those
three strategies I gave you this morning
when we talked about identifying
constants and variables we talked about
writing you know relevant equations
usually geometric ones measurement ones
and then thirdly term what was the third
one the most important one we're most
the work is you're probably going to
have to find some derivatives of some
kind right now I haven't given you any
variables of any kind in here again
that's part of a question I'm gonna give
you a few minutes to have a play
look about see where you can go draw a
new diagram if you have to and if you
think you have an idea or you want some
nudges in the right direction call me
over okay off you go all right so it
looks like you guys need a bit of a hand
which is totally fine okay so you have
to flounder around a little bit you have
to stay in the pit a little while before
before I show it to you otherwise it's
just like oh it's just easy it is not
easy but let me hold your hand through
this okay now I started to hear everyone
knows okay we're gonna have to put some
pronumerals in here because the first
thing is you gotta identify some
constants or some variables okay now you
can call anything you'd like here
anything you'd like you mean the can
okay but I'm gonna make some arguments
for particular things and I'm gonna try
and convince you as to why okay here's
the first thing I'm gonna put in here
see this length between the lay-up the
streetlight where its position is on the
ground as compared to our person LeBron
whoever it is okay I'm going to call
that X now you don't have to call it X
you can call it anything you like you
may have used X but you might have used
it for something different
here's my reason for why I'm calling
that X okay the most important constant
in this question in fact it's the only
one I've bothered to highlight with a
different color
apart from this is the rate of change
the rate of change is central to what's
going on right I mean wearing the topic
rate of change yeah so I want to be able
to state this in a nice simple way if
the person is moving away from the lab
then that means that X is getting bigger
at that rate does that make sense
so therefore the derivative that goes
with that is the change in X as compared
to the change in time right it's a rate
so DX on DT and I can just say really
nice and simply that's equal to 1 you're
happy with that idea yeah okay now once
I've got this in place great I've got a
constant I can now start to sort out
what about all these variables here ok
now we all know because it's part of the
core of the question right that the
shadow is getting longer okay shadow I'm
going to call it s for shadow ok so
that's this lengthy and it's a variable
so in fact the growth of the shadow is
really D it's the change in s as
compared to time that's what I'm after